thank you very much for joining us
fighting between Sudan's Army and the
nation's biggest paramilitary Force has
entered its third day this is a scene
right now in Khartoum where there's been
more heavy gunfire into Monday morning
there was a brief lull on in violence on
Sunday during a three-hour humanitarian
pause fighting between the Army and the
rapid support Forces paramilitary Group
began on Saturday medical sources say at
least 97 people have been killed and
hundreds injured since then
this is a state of play in Sudan with
fighting now spread across the country
but the worst of it has been centered in
the capital Khartoum and the neighboring
city of umdorman both sides have been
vying for control of the state
broadcaster the presidential Palace the
airport and various military bases let's
get an update with our correspondent Eva
Morgan who joins us live from Khartoum
Hebrew bring us up to speed with the
situation this morning how intense is
the fighting today
oh
well it hasn't stopped since the early
hours of Monday morning and I don't know
if you can hear the sound of the heavy
artillery that's being fired around us
and that's coming from the vicinity of
the general command of the Army
Headquarters we understand from army
sources that the rapid support forces
try to launch attacks on the general
command headquarters and the Army has
been fighting back ever since there's
also the sound of fighter jets in
several uh over the over several
residential districts here in hortum
City especially the northern part of the
capital and the southern parts of the
capital where there are rapid support
bases residents say they can hear the
sound of the heavy artillery they can
hear the sound of anti-aircraft missiles
being fired by rapid support forces at
the Sudanese Army's fisa Jets which are
flying overhead and around us you can
still hear the sound of what seems to be
the confrontation between the rsf and
the military it's still not clear who
has the upper hands upper hand in this
battle both sides claim that they have
control of all major facilities but it's
not clear yet who has control of which
facility and for how long they'll be
able to hold on to it fully okay so we
can indeed hear that the sound of
gunfire behind you there and as you say
unclear still after three days of
violence who is in control or who has
the upper hand there was a brief
humanitarian pause on Sunday Hiba where
people able to get out and get food
Essentials
well both sides on Sunday agreed to a
three-hour ceasefire to allow for the
opening of humanitarian corridors and
they targeted specific people people who
were who were trapped in the vicinity of
fighting areas that is areas around the
presidential Palace like schools and
hospitals and around the general command
headquarters as well as where there are
rsf bases but that's three three hours
ceasefire did not last it lasted for
about an hour or so before fighting
resumed at least around the vicinity of
the Army Headquarters and the
presidential Palace now people in
Khartoum are not used to this fully
despite the fact that there have been so
many conflicts around the country never
in harsum so for many people they don't
know what to do they were not prepared
for a conflict between the two sides
they were not prepared they did not
store extra food they did not store
water many neighborhoods are Out of
Water and Power so lots of confusion and
then there's the issue of the injured
hundreds of people have been injured
many of them can't access medical
facilities because of this insecurity
and the on the streets of heartum
there's a lot of diplomatic effort right
now to try and end this fighting talk to
us about what we can expect Eber and is
there today a viable mediation effort
foreign
well the intergovernmental Authority for
development says it is going to send
Envoy specifically the head of South
Sudan Kenya and Djibouti to talk to the
two sides the rapid support Force
Commander and the commander of the army
uh to end the conflict but it's not
clear if they will be able to land Again
part of the current fighting is ongoing
around the airport and on the tarmac of
the airport there's been reports of fire
as well so it's not clear they'll be
able to land because they were reported
to have to arrive today on Monday now
will that be viable both sides say that
they want to take control of the other
the rsf says it will not stop fighting
until it takes control of all the Army
bases while the Army says it has
designated the rsf as a rebel group and
will set out to destroy it so it's not
clear if any mediation will have any
impact on both sides hey bud thank you
very much for the moment Tiba Morgan
live there in cartoon where gunfire
continues this Monday morning after
three days of fighting between the Army
and and the paramilitary force the rapid
forces and the fighting is threatening
of course to worsen what was already a
dire humanitarian situation in Sudan the
U.N humanitarian office is about 15.8
million people roughly a third of the
population will need assistance this
year they are 3.7 million internally
displaced people who need help around 4
million children under the age of five
and pregnant women are acutely
malnourished and need life-saving
services and as many as 11.7 million
people don't have enough food to eat
joining us now on the phone from
Khartoum is Dalia Muhammad who's a
resident of the Sudanese Capital Dalia
Muhammad Abdel munem and also an
activist Dalia thank you so much for
speaking to us I understand you live
next to the airport in Khartoum tell us
first what the night was like for you
and your family
um first of all thank you for having me
um I mean it was really
it started from around 3 30 4 o'clock we
could just give it just the fights are
just flying over our heads over our
homes and the sound of the weapons or
the ammunition that was being used was
different to what we were used to it
wasn't just bullets or artillery attacks
if there was like a whistling sound so
it's like something being dropped
so it hasn't let up I mean if they go
quiet for 10-15 minutes and then they
start all over again and it's really
beginning to take a toll on all of us
but there's not much we can do we're all
stuck indoors and we just have to try to
make the best of it if we can you say
you're all stuck indoors Dahlia there
was a brief pause yesterday in fighting
were you able to get out at all to to
get food to get essentialed were you
able to venture out not in our area not
in our area if anything it was the that
passage was supposed to start from four
o'clock the fighting intensified from
four o'clock until six o'clock which is
when uh we were supposed to break our
fast because it is still Ramadan so we
couldn't do anything but I do know
people in other other areas in of
Khartoum were able to go out and get
some supplies but there's also another
problem because a lot of factories
haven't been working and a lot there's
been power Cuts throughout the city so
all the super markets their produce and
their products have gone bad so even if
we were if even if we were able to get
to get out I don't think we would have
been able to find anything bakeries
aren't working you know there's no more
there's no movement between the uh the
urban and the rural areas so don't fresh
produce I'm imagining if there's any
packaged Foods they probably sorry they
probably would have gone bad by now
right so and as you see I think mainly
the passage yeah the passage was for
those who are injured or those who need
medical care or medical attention Okay
more than for those of you do you know
whether those people were able to to
reach hospitals
I honestly know I don't know on that on
that sense I don't know it's uh
yeah yeah as you said yeah this is a
very difficult time I can only imagine
what you and your family are going
through this is happening during the
holy month of Ramadan when people fast
most of the day uh during the day and
you know you have Eid at the end of
Ramadan uh they eat holiday coming in
just a few days tell us about what life
has been like for for you and your
family for the residents of cartoon
these past three days
are you worried that things could get
worse yeah
I think it will get worse simply because
they you know this this uptake in using
fighter just has really raised the
stakes I don't know how they will come
down from that how they will even agree
to meet even if the mediators are are
able to get into Sudan will they be able
to do anything because both burhan and
hamiti have said really strongly worded
statements and they don't seem to be
want to want to back down there is there
is no desire from either side to take a
step back and maybe say okay let's talk
or let's discuss or let's negotiate and
that's my fear that they've crossed that
line and there's no going back they it's
just they will just continue until one
of them remains standing or I don't know
something happens but I don't think
diplomacy is going to work right I don't
know what it is there a sense you get a
sense uh is there a sense of who has the
upper hand right now
no absolutely not we don't know who's in
control we don't know who controls the
airport we don't know who controls the
the national broadcaster we know nothing
I mean I I we don't know I mean I live
next to the airport I have no idea who's
outside all I hear is just the standard
artillery and the and the bullets but we
have no idea who is who and who and
which is you know which side has started
off firing at the other we don't know I
don't think anyone does know yeah a very
different and we can't take the
statements they release at face value
yeah thank you so much Dalia for talking
to us yeah thank you thank you for uh
sharing your experience with us Dalia
Mohammed Abdel monem a resident of
Khartoum telling us about her experience
over these past three days as intense
fighting continues uh in Sudan between
rival forces well top diplomats from the
US and UK have called for an immediate
end to the violence speaking on the
sidelines of the G7 foreign Minister's
Summit meeting rather in Japan and we've
got Al jazeera's Rob McBride who is
therefore is joining us live now tell us
about what's been said there about Sudan
Rob
that's right there have been a lot of
expressions of concern by participants
in this uh G7 foreign ministers meeting
since uh they started arriving here in
Japan uh Saturday through Sunday uh the
latest statement has come from Anthony
blinken the U.S Secretary of State and
it came a day photo opportunity just
ahead of a bilateral meeting with his
British counterpart James cleverley he
expressed his concern about what's going
on uh Lincoln said that the people of
Sudan want democracy and they want a
resumption of the talks that were moving
towards civilian Rule and he says the
way to allow that to continue he says is
for the military to get back to their
Barracks let's listen to what he said
I strongly help you again across all of
our partners on the need forth and
immediate ceasefire and a return to
talks
talks that were very promising in
putting Sudan on the path to a full
transition to civilian-led government
people in Sudan want the military back
in the barracks
they want democracy they want a civilian
LED government Sudan needs to return to
that path
this meeting has continued probably the
most important session this Monday has
been on the war in Ukraine with the G7
foreign ministers agreeing to continue
their United supporter for Ukraine
continuing sanctions against Russia and
also looking at ways of stopping Russia
getting around those sanctions and
stopping getting weapons from third
countries there are claims that Russia
has been receiving weapons from North
Korea and fears that China might also
start to supply Russia with weapons
thank you very much for that Rob McBride
live for us
Japan thank you